little kids killing each other wow these
are the kind of movies human beings like
Ender's Game Ender's Game is one of my
favorite movies of the year I'm going on
record do I see this film is perfect no
I honestly didn't give two shits about
this film before I saw it this is just
pure Hollywood escapism it's like The
Hunger Games in space now I never
actually read the book ender's game
which is cool to me because I'm going
off of the film on its own merits I'm
like a lot of you annoying douchebag
readers of bucks oh look at this scene
oh [ __ ] oh no the line actually went
like this in the book I'm kidding you
guys are actually way cooler than me I
really don't know how fast the novel are
gonna respond to this movie but as a
regular audience member of the cinema I
had a total blast let's start off with
talking about ender the character ender
is so smart so strategic some tactical
he's like mini solid snake from metal
gear solid but the character he is far
from being two-dimensional I'm not
saying he's two-dimensional I'm saying
he's far from being a two-dimensional
character that's where you bookworms out
there yeah it does deal a lot with his
badass free but it also deals a lot with
the psychology of ender how his past
experiences as upbringing have greatly
just ass [ __ ] him this guy's like 13
years old and I found myself going I
want to be this guy the guy who played
him was so good you can feel all the
repressed darkness inside of him and
you're also rooting for him like the
whole time even though you know he is
the [ __ ] and you can do anything you're
rooting for him every moment it's called
ender's game and ender rocks my [ __ ] but
he's 13 so he doesn't I just love all
the themes as film deals with from what
kind of leader you should be to not
letting your pass rule you I even
enjoyed some of its political themes
Obama would love this film not many
black people ended up dealing with
people's lives in the military and war
is it okay at times the film is much
darker than I anticipated it to be it
has a few moments that are very violent
like violence like how do they let kids
get away with doing this on screen it's
just ten times worse when you're
watching kids kick the [ __ ] out of each
other but at the end of the day who
want to see our hero pound on a fast
bully the visual effects is pretty damn
good I don't think it's necessarily
groundbreaking but it's pretty freakin
sweet to look at you know everything
from like the production design the art
design the costume design and there's
some action in it that is so [ __ ]
cool they have several types of action
adventure scenes and there's this one
game they play in Battle School [ __ ] it
just sounds so cool Battle School what
do you want to go to battle school gosh
you can pick up any chick at a bar if
you went to battle school who the [ __ ]
you want to [ __ ] with you if you went to
battle school if Conan O'Brien went to
battle school you would have kept it
tonight show anyway you'll know the game
that I'm talking about when you watch it
in both games ender is just super bad
ass he's not just intellectual he
doesn't need a sidekick I don't want to
give it away but there's just one point
and I think everyone felt this way when
they watched it where you go turn I wish
I could tell you a moment that was but
I'm not gonna ruin it for you but you
will do that noise that's what he meets
his rival played by Moises arias that
kid from Hannah Montana the shortest
scrawniest big nose tough guy you'll
ever see he's like the Mexican Joe Pesci
but not as scary but i do gotta say you
know for for being like a [ __ ] he did
a really good job in the role I could
see why some people were very
intimidated by him like that little
[ __ ] was up in my face I would bend
down to his level out of respect I just
love a movie that can create an entire
science fiction universe and bring
complete fantasy to life I wouldn't say
it's an immersive experience like
gravity the director keeps things moving
fast it's really fast paced but it
doesn't mean at times it feels like it's
rushing but overall it doesn't feel like
it's rushing they even introduce some
characters late into the film and some
characters that are very important
introduced in the beginning but you
don't see them for a long time at the
end of the day they're all there at the
right moments and they give strong
performances which leads me to talking
about Harrison Ford ender he does a
great job in this movie it's cool to see
him in the movie that yes it does have
action but he's not doing any of the
action it's just a pure acting role from
Harrison Ford he shows that he can
really Act doesn't need a whip no he
doesn't need air force one there doesn't
need to be a clear and present danger
happening at times he's a good guy at
times you question his intent but he's
always great to watch although he did
seem a little obsessed with a 13 year
old boy
that's probably the size of Moises arias
his penis the cool thing about ender
he's always put in situation's where he
has to come up with like a quick
strategy and then when he figures it out
it's always so cool like the problem
will present itself you'll wonder like
what's he gonna do I don't see a way how
we could possibly do this but the
writing is so good that it presents a
unique strategy and it makes sense why
no one can defeat king ender that's my
new name for him King anger talking
about the actor damn good the last half
hour of the zone has some great twists
of great reveals in fact to give one
complaint the end kind of leaves things
really open there's a lot of questions
that go unanswered and there's a lot of
things I just don't really get wrapped
up so you obviously have to finish the
franchise as far as this journey goes
it's pretty damn solid it's what i
consider cinema to be all about just
enough drama a universe you totally buy
with great adventure great thrills and
solid [ __ ] acting let me get straight
to the point here oh no league hace ya
head nurse gave got it super right
alright guys thanks for checking out my
review for Ender's Game why don't you go
ahead scroll that comment box below and
tell me was there ever a bully in your
school that you wanted to kick his ass
and what is his name and if you want to
go and follow me on twitter we can work
together i'm finding that bullies and
kicking the badasses and if you want to
see more in-depth review of Ender's Game
go ahead and check your by show called
reasons to see where we got special
guest on the show and Draya six toes
she's hot huh yeah mmm that game would
never end that doesn't make any sense
the last but not least you won't get
updated every time one of my reviews is
how cook on this one of am I dig to
subscribe huh that's right the penis
it's capable of doing a lot of things
telling you ender he wouldn't run out of
games to play with this bad boy
hear that that's the sound of me
becoming a registered sex offender